The world is watching as Russia wages war
on Ukraine.
But Russian state media is telling a different
story.
Media like the state-owned Russia 24 TV channel
have been following a narrative that President
Vladimir Putin laid out on the morning of the invasion.
The narrative in state media is one clearly
expressed by Putin in his address to the nation.
There is no war going on and it's forbidden
to use the word "war," as you know, you
should speak about a "special operation,"
and this "special operation" is considered
to be a liberation of Ukrainian people from
the Nazis, from ultranationalists in Kyiv.
A "special operation" to "liberate"
Ukraine is a cornerstone of the narrative.
Another is Russia's claim that its actions
are pacifism.
Pacifism was a very big part of Soviet, and
then Russian, propaganda, even if it was fake
pacifism.
War is bad and peace is good.
So what’s happening now, is that even those
propagandists who are supporting Putin, they
still try to use pacifist narratives.
According to Russia, it’s the US and NATO
that are threatening peace.
They're trying to present the situation as
if it's not a conflict between Russia and
Ukraine, it's a conflict between Russia and
America.
This is very important for Putin in this propaganda
campaign, not only to avoid negative information
coming from Ukraine, but also to keep the
idea that the West is conspiring against Russia.
World War II references and anti-Western rhetoric
are key ingredients fueling what some call
the Russian propaganda machine.
But there are signs the engine is stuttering.
Usually our propaganda machine is well-prepared
for all events because the directors of our
state TV channels and other big state media
are gathering every week on Thursdays in the
Kremlin, and they get instructions about how
to report about this and that.
But no one explained to them that there will
be war in Ukraine.
Their first narrative, right before
the war started, was that Putin said that
he is going to return troops back.
So it's all fake, a "fake Western hysteria"
about a possible war.
Russia is not going to wage a war against
anyone.
The machine normally works so well, in part
because independent reporting has become increasingly
scarce in Russia.
Watchdog Reporters Without Borders ranked
Russia as 150 out of 180 countries for press
freedom last year, saying that major TV channels
continued to inundate viewers with propaganda
and that vague and selective laws were used
to imprison journalists and bloggers.
Now it's understandable that it has been done
in advance, in order to [allow] the Kremlin
to control communication almost entirely.
And [that control] will increase.
Once Ukraine was invaded, the Kremlin’s
crackdown on media freedoms only intensified.
Two of Russia’s most significant remaining
independent media outlets – the Echo of
Moscow radio station and online TV channel
Dozhd – were forced to close.
During their last moments on air, Dozhd broadcast
a recording of Swan Lake – that state TV
aired on a loop during the collapse of the
Soviet Union.
We can tell that independent reporting from
Russia became practically impossible, only
those outside Russia – they can do it.
The main center of Russian independent media
is abroad, so they will not close all the
information by imprisoning these people who
are still now sitting in Russia.
Russia is not so much separated from the outside
world.
There is still the internet in the country.
Even though many independent media websites
are banned in Russia, they can still be accessed
via VPNs – "virtual private networks"
which disguise users’ IP addresses so that
internet providers – or the government – cannot
see which websites they are visiting.
Demand has surged in Russia for VPN apps since
war broke out in Ukraine.
Many say the internet, and especially social
media, have become the backbone of the anti-war
protests that have been taking place in Russia
despite an intense crackdown from police and
lawmakers.
I think it is actually ironic that in Western
countries over the last years, there has been
a narrative that old-school media checks information
and there is disinformation that goes through
the social networks.
In Russia, it’s vice versa – we have disinformation
that’s going through state media and there
is a window for independent media in social
networks.
So social networks, of course, play a very
important role.
But even though there is a window for reliable
information on social media – there is also
a huge amount of disinformation circulating
on the platforms.
Users have to know whom to trust.
But they might not even get the chance – Russia
has now blocked Facebook and Twitter.
Getting independent information on the war
is getting harder by the day.